why doesn't Twitter why doesn't a
text-based
comment as a first citizen based social
network have a billion users well I just
think it's hard to build these companies
so it's um you know it's not that every
idea
automatically goes and gets a billion
people it's just that I think that that
idea coupled with good execution should
get there
um but but I mean look we hit certain
thresholds over time where
you know we kind of plateaued early on
and it wasn't clear that we were ever
going to reach 100 million people on
Facebook and then we got really good at
dialing in internationalization and
helping the service grow in different
countries and
um and and that was like a whole
confidence that we needed to develop and
um and helping people basically spread
the service to their friends that was
one of the things once we got very good
at that that was one of the things that
made me feel like hey if if Instagram
joined us early on then I felt like we
could help grow that quickly and same
with WhatsApp and like that's sort of
been a core competence that we've
developed and been able to execute on
and others have two right I mean byte
dance obviously have done a very good
job with Tick Tock and and have um you
know reached more than a billion people
there but um but it's certainly not
automatic right I think you need you
need a certain level of of um of
execution to basically get there and you
know I think for whatever reason
I think Twitter has this great idea and
and sort of magic in the service
um but
I I they just haven't kind of cracked
that piece yet and I think that's made
it's that you you're seeing all these
other things whether it's Mastodon or
um or or blue sky
um that that I think are you know maybe
just different different cuts of the
same thing but you know I think through
the last generation of of um social
media overall
one of the interesting experiments that
I think should get run at larger scale
is what happens if there's somewhat more
decentralized control and if it's like
the stack is more open throughout and
um I've just been pretty fascinated by
that and seeing how that works
um
to some degree end-to-end encryption
um on WhatsApp and as we bring it to
other services provides an element of it
because it pushes the service really out
to the edges I mean the the
server part of this that we run for
WhatsApp
is relatively very thin compared to what
we do on Facebook or Instagram
and much more of the complexity is you
know and how the apps kind of negotiate
with each other to pass information in a
in a fully intent encrypted way
um but I don't know I think that that's
that is a good is a good model I think
it puts more power in individuals hands
and there are a lot of benefits of it if
you can if you can make it happen again
this is all like pretty speculative I I
mean I I think that it's it's you know
hard from the outside to know why
anything does or doesn't work until you
kind of take a run at it and
um
so I I think it's it's kind of an
interesting thing to experiment with but
I don't really know where this one's
gonna go